if your country was under attack by a
giant radioactive monster what would you
do tokyo is about to be destroyed and
your government is responsible for
stopping the creature in its tracks i'm
going to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to beat
godzilla in shin godzilla this country
is about to face a crisis like never
before the coast guard spot a stranded
yacht floating in tokyo bay finding only
some personal effects they wonder if
someone fell off the yacht and drowned
suddenly the sea erupts from below and
massive amounts of blood bursts into
this underwater highway the government
arranges a meeting to discuss what just
happened and they see on the news what
looks to be a volcanic eruption at tokyo
bay forcing people to evacuate the
government runs through a list of
possibilities including the idea of a
new volcano but one official interrupts
to say that the bay is too shallow for a
volcano yaguchi here tells the others
that their theories are all wrong
there's something in that bay they move
operations into a conference room as
more and more civilians keep evacuating
the area suddenly the government gets
word that eruption activity is dying
down but yakuchi here calls bs on that
and says that a massive creature could
be behind all of this but no one
believes him they watch another
broadcast and see a giant tail come out
of the ocean the government is split
between wanting to kill this creature as
soon as possible or capture it for
research this lady analyzes the video
and thinks that it may be capable of
walking on land the government then
decides to tell the world according to
experts it cannot come on to land it
would crush itself under its own weight
and tells the world to remain calm but
that's when this thing now destroying
anything on either side of the gnomey
river gets out of the water and onto
land wreaking havoc in the city and
thousands of people run for their lives
okay the government was way too calm
about everything leading up to this but
if you think about it their calm
reaction to the events leading up to
this actually makes sense why japan is
one of the few countries located above
what is called the ring of fire or the
circum-pacific belt it's a path along
the pacific ocean that traces the
boundaries between several tectonic
plates 75 of the earth's volcanoes more
than 450 of them are located along this
area a large portion of the planet's
most violent acts happen here japan is
no slouch when it comes to dealing with
natural disasters since the archipelago
is situated along this ring of fire this
country is vulnerable to natural
disasters such as earthquakes tsunamis
and volcanic eruptions in fact japan is
so used to all of this that it even has
a dedicated budget and massive systems
in place to deal with all of this they
have earthquake resistant buildings that
move with the earthquakes which means
that everything these guys have
experienced up to this point was pretty
much just another regular tuesday minus
the giant ugly monster crushing its way
through the city streets and ruining
people's lives this video is brought to
you by manscape.com the premium global
brand for men's grooming and hygiene
products but check it
it's friday night and you've got a hot
day with michiko malanju or satoru goju
whatever tickles your fancy either way
you're gonna need to keep those wee
pairs trimmed if you want your fanciest
tickle come end of the night that's why
manscape sent me the performance package
4.0 all-in-one grooming kit for body
hair removal
lawnmower 4.0 travel trimmer waterproof
cordless wireless charging and contain
whatever ungodly fluff you throw at it
we're talking replaceable ceramic blades
with skin safe tech on this bad boy no
mess no cuts no nicks because the last
time i tried shaving south of my grand
canyon i nicked some soft spots but this
led spotlight will light up your soft
spots and have your heart to reach
places ready for whatever happens after
that hot date of yours now fun fact
about me is i collect watches this is my
next pick 21 jewels it's nice right well
too bad for us guys we've only got two
jewels and i'm talking about your family
jewels gentlemen your balls so you got
to take care of them because the
performance package 4.0 also includes a
crop preserver which you can apply on
your sweet money makers after the shower
for all-day body odor protection and top
it off with the crop reviver for a
midday refresh session all this will
make your wrinkly raising sack look more
sexy than my watch collection oh [ __ ] is
that a nose here what with the weed
whacker you don't gotta worry about it
this thing is like the 4.0 lawn mower
but for your nose if this can handle my
big schna's it can handle yours too and
my love language is gift giving just
kidding it's gift receiving so for a
limited time when you get the 4.0
performance package you'll get two free
gifts this luxury leather
water-resistant grab-and-go shed travel
bag and the super comfortable
anti-chafing box of briefs to house that
nasty jungle eel of yours so get your
ass over to manscape.com and get 20 up
plus free shipping and two free gifts
with my promo code link down below and
go to manscape.com thank you to
manscape.com for sponsoring this video
now back to the show the creature going
through tiny streets tramples everything
in its path going at a pace of 8 miles
an hour giving the government only 3
hours until it reaches tokyo city the
government in an emergency meeting
quickly works on a plan they talk about
a military strike but the area is too
densely populated for them to use any
heavy artillery they then argue about
the steps it would take to move everyone
out of the area knowing it would result
in a massive gridlock leaving tens of
thousands of terrified people trapped
with little choice they decide to go
ahead with the evacuation arranging for
emergency personnel to help people
escape on foot the giant creature climbs
onto an apartment tips it over and kills
everyone inside the government watches
the entire thing play out and realizes
that it's now or never they authorize
for defense forces to attack the
creature head-on even while thousands of
citizens are fleeing the area and they
need the final attack order from the
prime minister government officials tell
the prime minister that he needs to take
action now or it'll be too late military
attack helicopters are sent off and the
government officials pat themselves on
the back for taking care of the threat
meanwhile the creature stops gets on its
back legs and collapses sending debris
and dust all over everyone freezes not
knowing what is going to happen next
suddenly it stands back up and begins
evolving rapidly gaining size and
turning into a much deadlier creature
and into japan's greatest enemy godzilla
now it begins walking through the city
at a much faster pace and that's when
the military arrives on the scene taking
position to gun down this deadly
creature once and for all they ready
their guns to fire but notice civilians
still evacuating the city the prime
minister gives them orders to hold off
their attack in order to ensure the
safety of the remaining escapees but
that was his biggest mistake godzilla
sprints through the buildings and heads
straight back into tokyo bay the
government officials visit the disaster
zone shocked at the amount of damage
caused in only two hours they worry that
the creature is hiding in the bay and is
going to make another appearance very
soon should a major move when it was
just crawling on the ground now we have
to decide if using munitions against
godzilla is worth human lives and the
long-term effects if we don't up front
cost of life that we put in harm's way
versus the millions of lives that
godzilla will kill the longer it remains
alive we have no way of knowing yet if
our weapons will work against godzilla
and the last thing we want to do is piss
it off but what choice do we have we
gotta do something and we're lucky that
godzilla wasn't able to stay on land
many sea creatures are often crushed by
their own weight if they even attempt to
make land including mammals such as
whales and godzilla it seems is no
exception this is evident as there is
little reason that godzilla would have
returned to see if it didn't have to
since it was met with basically no
resistance when it made land it is being
driven exclusively by instinct meaning
it didn't go back into the sea because
it was bored it went back because it had
to we need to assume it's coming back
and we need to get a move on getting
ready for it if i was them i would
quickly get over the fact that countless
lives will die but if we want our kids
to have a home to return to we have no
choice and the fact that they only used
kawasaki oh1 ninja scout helicopters to
take it on is insane yakuchi arranges an
informal meeting and gathers experts of
every discipline to add their two cents
in regards to the apocalyptic threat at
hand they look at the three mutations of
the creature thinking there's more to
come however they can't get a good read
on it with the limited information they
have they want to know what kind of
energy source could fuel a creature this
big this lady doctor suggests that
godzilla might be using nuclear energy
to power its gargantuan frame they begin
analysis of the creature's path
throughout the city and notice that it's
left a path of radiation wherever it
went that's when the us deputy chief's
aide requests a meeting with yakuchi the
deputy chief's aide kaioko strikes a
deal with yakuchi and asks him to find a
japanese professor who knew that
godzilla was going to attack years
before it ever happened she wants them
to hand over the professor in exchange
for u.s intel on the creature later the
government informs her that the
professor's boat was found missing a few
days ago and hands over the intel that
they recovered from the ship in exchange
the lady hands over her intel on
godzilla they analyzed the intel that
kayoko gave them looking at classified
photos showing the mass dumping of
radioactive materials into the ocean the
lady confirms that this is what the
creature fed on to become the giant
behemoth they see today the experts
discussed their new findings discovering
that godzilla is capable of
self-mutation making it an increasingly
powerful force to reckon with however
the creature is mortal and it can be
killed one of the experts questioned why
it returned to tokyo bay and this bald
man has a realization this creature has
a biological nuclear reactor in its body
and it needs to return to the bay in
order to cool off this is beyond bad
we've got a prehistoric creature that
powers itself by feeding a nuclear waste
and radiation usually isn't too nice to
biological matter it's helped with
advances in medicine academics
agriculture archaeology like carbon
dating geology and even more but all the
same radiation is scary because
radiation is basically the emission of
energy in the form of waves or particles
through space or through a material
medium like radium a naturally occurring
radioactive metal this stuff at high
doses has the ability to damage dna in
our cells causing a bunch of horrifying
stuff to happen within the body
mutagenic effects cellular degradation
and even organ failure like seriously
don't type up radiation poisoning on
google this stuff is so volatile the
human species along with every other
species consists of trillions of cells
godzilla getting power from radiation
means that every single one of his
trillions of cells within his body would
have had to mutate the exact same way
which is highly unlikely exhausted
yaguchi takes a nap but his subordinate
rushes in and says that godzilla is back
the massive creature rises from the
ocean and makes its way back onto land
destroying homes businesses everything
in its path causing horrified civilians
to run the government watches from the
meeting room and realizes something
extremely worrying the creature has
nearly doubled in size the analytics
still project that godzilla will reach
tokyo metropolitan area in three hours
and the government officials fear that
it might be headed towards a nuclear
facility on the way which would result
in a large-scale massive disaster that
would last decades crippling the country
great just great now it wants a nuclear
snack for dessert japan is no slouch
when it comes to nuclear energy this
type of energy usage has been a national
priority for them since 1973. in fact
from 1970 onwards japan has only
quadrupled their nuclear power capacity
to the point where up until 2011 japan
was generating some 30 percent of
electricity from its reactors with plans
to only increase until the fukushima
accident of course which kind of threw a
wrench into that plant as of 2022 japan
has 33 nuclear power reactors classed as
operable meaning that godzilla has
plenty to choose from this animal is
driven by instinct unless we can find
out the path of least resistance for him
and in which direction he's headed we
don't know which power plant to protect
from him because shutting down a power
plant removing the nuclear fuel from the
reactor itself the whole process can
take seven years for the whole area to
be rendered inoperable and harmless
everyone panics knowing what's about to
come they begged the prime minister to
let them fire at the creature and
finally the prime minister announces
that they're clear to commence attack
the command center declares the city of
kawasaki a battleground getting ready
for all-out war ground forces begin
gathering and they're briefed on the
radioactive material present on
godzilla's head and legs the choppers
arrive on the scene and they're given
the order to fire instantly a barrage of
bullets drill godzilla in the face but
it has no effect the chopper squad
switches their ammo to higher artillery
bullets but still nothing godzilla
pushes forward getting closer to tokyo
the command center is shocked to see
that 16 000 bullets hasn't left a mark
so they have the choppers take position
and fire missiles right at the
creature's face a cloud of black smoke
covers godzilla but he emerges with no
visible signs of damage seeing this the
command center shifts to phase two of
their defense plan the ground tanks aim
and all fire at the same time shooting
their weapons onto its lower body and
notice that godzilla is slowing down
they're on to something on the count of
three they commence artillery fire and
engage all forces onto the creature
simultaneously and the command center
moves on to phase three they launch an
all-out aerial assault bringing fighter
jets in to draw bombs from above the
entire city shakes from the impact and
the jets continue to throw heavy fire
while godzilla throws a part of the
bridge into the air landing right next
to the command center suddenly it
emerges from the debris with seemingly
no injuries the government decides that
the best option is to suspend operations
the attack was a failure and godzilla is
still getting closer to tokyo the
officials begin to realize that the
japanese defense force is not strong
enough to take on the creature by itself
they need outside help and they decide
to reach out to the us for aid the u.s
replies instantly proposing a bombing
zone that will kill tens of thousands of
civilians instantly if they're not
evacuated in time that's when one of the
officials confronts the prime minister
and tells him that he needs to leave now
godzilla is coming their way and they
need to get out of here really that's
what we're gonna do japan's security
treaty with the us has been in effect
since the 1960s these two nations are
committed to defending each other if one
of them is attacked the us has over 20
u.s military bases located in and around
japan but this solution could be worse
than dealing with godzilla ourselves the
u.s wants to take him out with a couple
of b2 spirit bombers which is a heavy
strategic bomber designed at taking out
anti-aircraft defenses and is capable of
delivering both conventional and nuclear
munitions this bomber aside from nuclear
munitions has the ability to hold up to
60 000 pounds of explosives which for
scale in simple terms a bomb is often
identifiable by its weight and even the
simplest of bombs within the 2 000 pound
range of explosives will usually carry
around about 940ish pounds of some type
of explosive charge ranging from tnt rdx
and ammonium nitrate or something else
the blast from a 2 000 pound charge will
be enough to carve a crater 50 feet
across and around 16 feet deep into the
ground all of this from just a simple 2
000 pound explosive charge and a single
b2 spirit bomber will be capable of
creating this much destruction times 30.
it won't be possible to evacuate all the
citizens in time which means their only
options is to have some sort of miracle
and survive in the japan metro tunnel
and the problem with that is that most
of the subway stations simply won't work
due to the fact that they are shallow
most of the metros underground in japan
do not surpass 30 meters deep this means
that japan is simply not prepared for
the creative destruction and nuclear
capabilities that godzilla is capable of
and neither will they be able to survive
if those b2 spirit bombers decide to
rain down hell on godzilla in any sort
of significant way dropping warheads
onto a walking nuclear reactor doesn't
seem like a good plan it would decimate
japan godzilla now in meguro city almost
the doorstep to the heart of tokyo
yaguchi and the others make their way
out but the entire city is under
gridlock they exit the car and hear
bomb-like sounds in the distance the
gigantic creature's footsteps are
deafening yakuchi's body tells him that
the us bomb strikes are coming earlier
than expected that's when the bombs hit
and they watch as the us firepower
causes massive bleeding to godzilla the
creature screams out in pain and yaguchi
notices that it's beginning to glow a
purple hue no one has any idea what's
going on when suddenly it bends over and
volcanic smog shoots out of its mouth
filling the city in a matter of seconds
it sets the smog on fire and destroys
everything on the ground godzilla lifts
its head upwards turning its fiery
breath into a terrifying beam of light
demolishing the bomber from above and
more bombers head towards it but
godzilla isn't done firing more beams of
light from its back it destroys the
bombers and the munitions they've
dropped down and continues to set the
city on fire yaguchi watches in all and
his buddy tells him to head underground
the next day the news reports that
radiation has spread throughout the
entire city of kawasaki and beyond the
prime minister has gone missing and they
need to find a replacement as soon as
possible yaguchi and his buddy walks
into the new government headquarters
located in tachigawa city he demands to
know the current location of godzilla
and is told that it's currently inactive
near tokyo station and the areas around
the creature are now highly contaminated
making it impossible for anyone to get
near it the minister of agriculture is
announced as the new prime minister
yaguchi gathers the experts one last
time giving them a pep talk and tells
them that they must stop the deadly
creature and gives them live samples of
the creature for research kayoko arrives
to inform them that other countries
would like to get involved in the fight
yaguchi meets with foreign experts and
they watch as a floating surveillance
system closes in a godzilla but loses
signal before they can get a good look
at the creature the foreign expert
explains that it may have something
similar to a built-in phase radar
allowing it to intercept incoming
objects this keeps getting worse and
worse godzilla has a built-in radar
that's a problem we as humans use faced
array radar systems for military and
non-military purposes the radar system
was developed for use in military radar
systems steering a beam of radio waves
into the sky to quickly detect planes
and missiles this explains how godzilla
knew and was able to defend itself when
the military tried to attack it earlier
now we also know that godzilla is not
only capable of releasing nuclear energy
but it's also leaking nuclear waste
wherever it goes at this point aside
from what the government is trying to do
to combat godzilla what they need to
figure out how to do is to move him away
from the city if godzilla keeps leaking
nuclear waste all over tokyo there won't
be a city left to live in a group goes
and inspects the disaster zone and
notices the remains of godzilla hanging
from above the experts analyze it and
find that the remains are capable of
becoming their own living organisms
yaguchi and kayoko meet up to discuss a
very important matter the white house
wants to use a giant nuclear warhead to
take out godzilla if it isn't stopped
the creature might make its way to
american shores and become a global
crisis kayoko tells him that the bomb
they're going to use will be 75 times
stronger than the one dropped on
hiroshima the prime minister tells his
subordinates that there's not much they
can do and asks them for permission to
go ahead with a nuclear strike his
subordinates are shocked knowing that
this will affect tokyo and japan for
decades to come the government gives the
united states the go-ahead to vaporize
tokyo and the experts suggest that
there's only two choices to make blow it
up with a nuke and suffer the
consequences or freeze it with a newly
formulated drug however creating this
drug will require 672 kilometers of
coagulation yakuchi demands that they
find a way and they get to work and they
call all the chemical companies in the
country hoping to find a way to make
this less dangerous option work out the
prime minister and his subordinates meet
again bringing news about godzilla in 15
days the creature will move again and
he'll be even deadlier than before
hearing this news the american
government gives them a two-week grace
period before dropping the bombs now
they have to evacuate 3.6 million people
from the tokyo metropolitan area okay
godzilla will resume activity in 15 days
and the us is saying that japan has two
weeks to evacuate 3.6 million people
from the area are they nuts the
resources and efforts necessary will be
immense and even then where would they
go you're going to need a huge amount of
housing and food to care for these
people for a long time we need all modes
of transportation both military and
civilian to take as many people as far
away from tokyo as possible the us since
it's their great idea to incinerate all
of tokyo have bases all over japan and
they can lend us their planes and ships
as well it's the least they can do this
bomb they're going to drop on tokyo is
75 times stronger than the bomb little
boy which was dropped on hiroshima the
death toll is going to be catastrophic
either way moving millions of people is
not easy the largest evacuation by a
civil airliner for example was the
moving of 170 000 people from oman to
bombay during the persian gulf war and
this evacuation took nearly two months
we got two weeks even if we're talking
about the evacuation within the country
places like tokyo are going to be unable
to do this within two weeks at least
humanely unless some type of big
international military effort aid was
given later on yaguchi continues to look
at the intel about the japanese
professor that knew about godzilla the
professor's wife died of radiation
sickness so he made it his life's work
to make radioactive material harmless
but they can't figure out the research
he left behind wondering why there are
lines drawn all over it that's when the
older expert takes another look at the
origami lying on the table and realizes
something extraordinary the experts get
to work figuring out that the
professor's research paper turns into a
molecular chart when folded like origami
with the scientific details figured out
they find that godzilla can convert
either hydrogen or oxygen into the
necessary molecules to keep its body
heated up and ready for action using
supercomputers they solve the
professor's riddle and take a look at
the scientific data they find out that
the blood coagulation plan freezing
godzilla from the inside out is possible
yakuchi's buddy confronts the prime
minister asking him to step aside so
they can try out the less deadly blood
coagulation plan the prime minister
disagrees telling them that the u.s
wants to get the issue over and done
with as soon as possible however later
realizing that yagerji's plan will
result in less death and destruction he
changes his mind with two days left
until the grace period is over yaguchi's
crew realizes that they need three days
to formulate the drugs yaguchi and
kayoko make an agreement with kyoko
supplying whatever weapons and equipment
necessary to undergo the coagulation
plan with hours until the creature
reawakens yakuchi gathers troops and
informs them that they'll be heading to
the disaster zone where godzilla awaits
he warns them that some may not make it
back and that the future of japan is in
their hands okay this is it it's the
final countdown godzilla is capable of
rapidly evolving to compensate and rid
itself of any weaknesses and this is how
the military hasn't been able to defeat
it yet godzilla's blood and dorsal
spikes act as a natural cooling system
for its body and this blood coagulant
that they're gonna try and stick
godzilla with will ideally interrupt his
blood cooling system with the intent of
freezing his body from within rendering
him immobile so to speak while this plan
does seem to have some risk it's the
only thing that we've got that won't
render japan and possibly the whole
world unlivable the us plans to use a
thermonuclear bomb on godzilla that's 75
times stronger than the one dropped on
hiroshima and here's the thing the
americans seem to need to pound a nail
with a sledgehammer instead of just a
regular hammer common sense will tell us
that based on what we've seen as to how
godzilla reacts to radiation one of two
things will happen the bomb will drop
and will either make godzilla thrive off
of the nuclear blast resulting in this
creature having even more terrifying
power or the bomb will cause godzilla to
receive too much energy making him
unstable and could result in everything
around him being in danger of
radioactive poisoning can you imagine
detonating the world's most powerful
nuclear warhead weapon on top of the
world's most dangerous walking living
breathing nuclear reactor godzilla it's
not gonna end well and while this act
may take down godzilla it could take
everything else down with it resulting
in a nuclear meltdown of sorts the likes
of which the world has never seen i'm
just saying the smartest thing we could
do is to try the blood coagulation plan
and see if it works arriving at tokyo
they enact a curfew on the entire city
and put the coagulation plan into motion
they send train cars to godzilla's
immobile body blowing them up and waking
the sleeping beast that's when the air
force arrives dropping bombs but they're
destroyed by his laser beams but the
planes keep on coming in order to waste
its energy they then notice that the
beams have stopped discharging but then
godzilla shoots laser beams from its
tail and mouth and suddenly the creature
runs out of energy and the laser beams
stop yakuchi's team blows up the
buildings around it forcing it to fall
to the ground they send out more
missiles to take out bigger buildings
burying godzilla the crane platoon makes
their entrance and gathers around the
creature's mouth to administer pressure
into its body that's when it wakes up
and takes out the entire platoon but
yakuchi here has a backup plan he sends
off more train bombs to hit the creature
with the second and third crane platoons
arriving on the scene they finish
administering the oxygen but godzilla
reawakens with killer intent suddenly
the creature freezes in place and the
mission is a success later on jagerjee's
subordinate congratulates him on the
gargantuan effort he informs him that
the entire cabinet is resigning meaning
japan will soon have another election
take place with yakuchi having a strong
case to become the new prime minister
but what did you think about shin
godzilla let us know what you like and
what you didn't like don't forget to
subscribe leave a thumbs up and as
always don't forget to check out our how
to beat playlist